pour rompre le désert alimentaire agricole
et commencer à corriger ce système alimentaire dysfonctionnel
que nous avons créé.
Cela peut sembler être une très petite réponse
à un gros, un énorme problème, de juste planter des fleurs.
Mais quand les abeilles ont accès à une bonne nourriture,
nous avons accès à une bonne nourriture
grâce à leurs actions de pollinisation.
Quand les abeilles ont accès à une bonne nourriture,
elles peuvent mieux mobiliser leurs propres défenses naturelles,
leur service de santé,
dont elles dépendent depuis des millions d'années.
La beauté de cette façon d'aider les abeilles, pour moi,
c'est que chacun d'entre nous doit se comporter
un petit peu plus comme une société d'abeilles, une société d'insectes,
où chacune de nos actions individuelles
peut contribuer à une solution d'ensemble,
une propriété émergente,
qui est bien plus que la simple somme
de nos actions individuelles.
Faisons en sorte que le modeste acte de planter des fleurs
et de les préserver des pesticides
soit le moteur d'un changement à grande échelle.
Au nom des abeilles, merci.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Merci. Juste une question rapide.
Les derniers chiffres de l'extinction des abeilles,
y a-t-il des signes indiquant un fléchissement ?
Quel est votre niveau d'espoir/dépression à ce sujet ?
Maria Spivak : Oui.
Aux États-Unis, en tout cas,
nous perdons en moyenne 30 % de nos ruches
chaque hiver.
Il y a 20 ans,
nous en étions à 15 % de pertes.
Alors ça devient précaire.
C. A. : Ce n'est pas 30 % par an, c'est... M. S. : Oui, c'est 30 % par an.
C. A. : 30 % par an ! M. S. : Oui, mais les apiculteurs
peuvent diviser leurs colonies et ainsi maintenir leur nombre,
ils peuvent recouvrer une partie de leurs pertes.
Nous en sommes à un tournant, en fait.
Nous ne pouvons pas vraiment nous permettre d'en perdre beaucoup plus.
Nous devons être vraiment reconnaissants
envers tous ces apiculteurs. Plantez des fleurs.
C. A. : Merci.
(Applaudissements)